Speaker 1: Welcome back, everybody, to the
David Pakman show. Luke Beasley here filling
in for David while he is away. Let's dive right
in. Well, the Tennessee House Republican effort
and successful temporarily effort to expel two
out of three of the Tennessee three as they're
being called, are the Democratic state lawmakers
who protested the inaction of Republicans on
the House floor peacefully. And because of their
violation of the decorum rules, they were expelled
by Republicans in the state of Tennessee, the
House of Representatives specifically. And this
has backfired epically, not only raising even
more attention to the fact that Republicans
are unserious about actually solving the issues
that face Americans or citizens, and to see more
specifically. And, of course, that applies to
gun violence in such a disastrous way. And it's
backfired beyond that as well, because now one
of the individuals they expelled, Justin Jones,
has been reinstated to his position as
a Tennessee state representative. And
the way that this works. And then we'll
dive into some videos from this and some
reporting on it. The Nashville Metropolitan
Council is the entity, the legislative body.
That is responsible. Whenever a
situation like this takes place,
a state representative is expelled. The Nashville
Metropolitan Council, four representatives that
represent that area is responsible for choosing
who's going to be the interim representative. So
here they're choosing Justice Justin Jones to be
the interim for the seat. He got expelled from
and then he'll hold that until an election. And if
he chooses to run for it, I'm sure he'll be able
to actually get back in through that as well. So a
complete failure in so many different ways on the
part of the Republican Party in Tennessee. Take a
look at this from CNN and then we'll look at some
videos from this. After being sworn back into
the Tennessee House of Representatives Monday,
a lawmaker who was expelled just days ago over
a gun control demonstration on the chamber floor
says he'll continue to call for gun reform.
Quote, The first thing I do when I walk into
this building as a representative is to continue
that call for common sense gun legislation, Justin
Jones said. Jones and another black Democrat,
Justin Pierson, were forced out of the Republican
controlled legislature last week after a protest
on the chamber floor spurred by the mass shooting
last month at a Nashville Christian school that
left six people dead. A third Democrat who joined
them in the protest and in protest, Representative
Claude Johnson, avoided expulsion. And then it
notes there, the Nashville Metropolitan Council
voted 36 to 0 Monday to re-appoint Jones to the
House of Representatives. Putting him back
into his same previously held position. And
I will show you this swearing in here.
Speaker 2: Let's talk a little bit about
Justin Jones, the state representative. He has
just is just now being sworn in only moments ago,
being sworn in as the new state representative
after he was expelled a few days ago because he
was protesting in favor of gun reform. And the
Republicans in the state legislature expelled
him and now he's being was just voted by the city
council there to be reinstated in Nashville. And
now he's just been sworn in. A very, very
dramatic development indeed. Let's talk.
Speaker 1: And credit to. The
Nashville City Council for doing this.
Um. Absolutely correct decision there. And then
I'll show you a little bit of his remarks out
in front of the Tennessee Capitol.
Speaker 3: Today, we're sending a
resounding message that democracy will not
be killed in the comfort of silence, trust.
Today, we send a clear message to
Speaker Cameron Sexton that the people
will not allow his his crimes against
democracy to happen without challenge.
The people of Nashville have spoken today through
their council members and democracy. We stand for
the vision of a multiracial democracy. Democracy
is our is the vision we're offering to this body,
this building that has forgotten it. It.
Speaker 1: And I've talked about this more
extensively on my show. You can find that at Luke
Beazley on YouTube. But just the way that nothing
represents more accurately than what we're
watching play out in Nashville, Tennessee,
the incorrect nature of the ideology of much of
the Republican Party, especially when it comes to
gun violence in the way that we address gun
violence. And while there are multiple fronts
in which we need to fight that battle,
make sure we're implementing solutions.
That is a multifaceted approach. But you can't
honestly want to address the unique to America
problem that we have here with gun violence and
ignore the gun control element. Other things too.
Mental health to school safety. To all of that.
And gun control. And so the fact that the focus
after this mass shooting by Tennessee Republicans
was not to implement those common sense solutions,
but instead to focus on expelling members who
were calling for those commonsense solutions
highlights the broken nature of this ideology
better than much else for sure. And then just
to round this out here is representative.
Justin Jones walking back into the chamber.
So there it is. Good for the people of.
Tennessee. Justin Jones, the Nashville
City Council. Shame on the Republicans, of
course, for causing this whole situation.
And we'll see how it continues to play out.